now jimmy you're the best you're the
king of games on your show i feel like
you sat the bar and so we wanted to try
a game with you here we've never done it
before
um it's a trivia with a twist it's
called who knew don't spew yeah i don't
know
i don't even like i don't like the title
i don't like the title already i'm
already freaking out well i know i know
your worst fears so ross explain the
game oh my god jimmy is so nervous okay
i'm going to ask general trivia
questions you're each going to answer
the same question using your whiteboards
and for every wrong answer you have to
take a step closer to your worst
nightmare it's not mayonnaise right well
jimmy you know whoever gets the the
prize right is going to win a prize for
your side of the audience jimmy you're
playing for the left side over here yeah
come on
[Applause]
you're going to play for guys right side
of the audience over here
and jimmy i feel like it's rigged i feel
like this is rigged okay and then you're
gonna you'll you'll take a step for
every wrong answer toward the box
whoever reaches the yellow circle first
oh my gosh we'll have to eat whatever is
under the box now you mentioned
something that you don't like better not
be pleased
it can't be mayonnaise you can't oh it
can't be mayonnaise i will i will throw
up if it's panicking what's your worst
fear drew goat's cheese oh yeah you know
what i knew this about both of you let's
take a look what's under there
[Music]
we have
it's so
[Applause]
big jimmy spirits with the mayonnaise
are you ready look at that i can't even
look at it but i will win for you guys i
will win okay
okay here's
here is the first question this is easy
uh which president is on the one dollar
bill
write down your answer if you get it
right you stay put if you get it wrong
you have to step towards your worst fear
drew george washington
yes you both got it right jimmy got it
right too
clear you're bored this is such a
curveball okay question number two what
is the largest continent
drew wrote her answer down she wrote
asia
oh wait
jimmy reveal yours wakanda
sadly drew got it right you're jimmy and
that's incorrect so you're going to step
to our pink dot
are you sure what count is that bigger
i'll check it but i think it is asia all
right uh next question
name kim kardashian's four children in
chronological order
drew's writing
wait wait all right reveal your answer
drew you wrote north
saint question mark psalm
not i mean really close though i have to
say jimmy what did you write down i
wrote a stick jack carl and tony
any of them right
well you're both going to walk forward
one step chicago right north saint
chicago
okay next question what is the periodic
symbol for potassium
drew wrote down poe
and jimmy wrote down
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of people knew that how about this
this question's worth five points
is it yes well you're both stepping
forward that's all i know okay step
forward this one this one's worth five
points
one two three
yeah whoever gets this one wins all
right so here's the question johnny
carson was the host of the tonight show
and for 30 years
what was his astrological sign
any other question any other question i
could get johnny carson what what what
car did he drive wow what is this
astrological sign
oh my god you know if i didn't know if
johnny knew
i think we went ahead and astrological
all right reveal it drew wrote scorpio
jimmy wrote virgo
why are you laughing well because there
were actually two answers i would accept
libra or scorpio because he was on the
cuffs but he was not
a virgo
but jimmy
you must
step forward
i'm honestly really freaking out right
now this is like honestly
hold up we got you a little one right
here
all right let me hold on hold on hold on
let me just focus out i don't know i
don't want to use a real spoon either
way
all right just a pinky okay we'll take a
pinky will we accept a pinky yes
i see too much on my pinky i put too
much of my pinky on there
oh jimmy oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
okay okay
get it off just gonna get it off yeah
can you get it off with this please here
we go here i'll just here you guys
anything to get this off my body it is
unbelievable okay does my side get any
prize at all
so
does my side get any prize at all
no
it is
better jimmy you did lose yeah which is
a very rare thing but but good news
you're all going home with a 100 gift
card to bookshop
[Applause]
bookshop.org supports local bookstores
and that is so important i love
booksellers of all varieties and also
you can get a copy of course of the one
and only
nana loves you more
jimmy's new book in his
franchise
of children's books and it's available
now online and in stores oh my gosh you
were so brave i will say a true friend
would eat the goat cheese
to support
jimmy
yeah you're right that's actually a
great idea i guess it just occurred to
me
oh
all right guys
[Music]